6 14 it's friday morning this is i love
this stuff a local brewery giving back
to help local firefighters with a brand
new brew it's craft house of course we
love their beer to begin with but now
they have station house and they're
going to be serving it this weekend so
we've got dave forest the owner of craft
house brewery in henderson and downtown
a co-owner with his wife wendy there and
dixon keller who represents the angel
fire department so first of all thank
you both so much for being with us this
morning and i guess we're just going to
jump right in and talk about
what it is dave that kind of inspired
you to make this beer and and what makes
it kind of stand out from your other
brews
hi heather good morning and good morning
john thank you so much for having us um
this is a really really special beer for
us it's our third annual station house
brew we do this with henderson
firefighter benevolent association and
the the beer stands out in that it's a
lager it's got a little bit of smoky
malt to it as well that gives it that
nice hue and it tastes absolutely crisp
clean and delicious and it'll be
available tomorrow at our annual event
love that
love that dave so um you talked about
the benevolent association with
henderson firefighters uh what is it
about what they do that motivated you
and the business to brew this beer and
help out
well they uh they're an organization
that helps the community that's the most
important thing and and they also take
care of the firefighters association and
with working with them and collaborating
this beer we also donate a portion of
the proceeds to angel fire as well
and angelfire a lot of people may not be
familiar with that so
see and you know dixon if you're able to
kind of just talk to us a little bit
about what this non-profit does and and
who it helps
absolutely angel fire department is a
501c3 non-profit and it's similar to
make-a-wish even though make-a-wish is
our one of our biggest partners but just
imagine putting a smile on the face of a
child that is injured who is terminal or
was sick and putting him in a fire
department or excuse me in a fire truck
and letting him shoot the water cannon
and have the lights and siren going and
puts a smile on their face and that's
what we do and we also support veterans
in our community but it's just giving
back to the community and making people
happy and that's what we do and we'd
really like to thank the henderson fire
department the firefighters benevolent
association and chief white for
supporting us because they really give
us a home to live in but we also need
community support because we have to
keep these fire engines running for the
kids love that dixon it sounds like a
it's a great cause and good to give the
kids a little bit of a smile as well i
love those fire trucks the kids can
enjoy the fire trucks and get a smile
from that and
dave can they can enjoy the brew and the
beer i love and a dark lager yes i'm
already red what time is it six o'clock
okay well we had margaritas yesterday so
yeah yeah
it is tomorrow tomorrow okay gotcha uh
so again family friendly event tomorrow
here at craft house in henderson 12 to
3. we'll have a food truck we'll have
photo ops with the truck as well and we
have a special soda that we made just
for the kids a strawberry cheesecake so
come and check it out oh that's good
stuff thank you both so much for being
on the show this morning it sounds
delicious looks wonderful what a great